as custodial parent i supposed to know
exactly what's what
kim can i leave now can you please tell
me where you cut my children's hair i
gave authority i gave my kids a haircut
you had no authority did you cop do you
have my kids behind her
did you consult with me
let me peel off did you consult with me
can i leave now let's be a man for once
consult with me
ma can you get the police because
yeah he's taking my photo because cause
he cut their hair
let's say cause he cut the hair let's
say i agree with you let's say i'm like
you know what woman you're right you
probably shouldn't have done that
you're gonna call the police on your
children's father
in front of them inflicting that kind of
trump for even if she's in the right and
he shouldn't have done that and i agree
with i give you that
you're going to call the cops i want a
relationship he got with cops he won't
tell me exactly what happened he has no
right to do that
i asked you a simple question so your
mom gonna get the police i don't know
i want you guys to pee how she's
implying that something might happen if
you don't do it is such a power movie
question where did you do this
earl they don't really making the kids
nervous earl
i know my own children ever since
ever since what i know my children ever
since you abandoned them
okay oh i thought i love you no i'm
recording it too just to make sure that
we're even steven okay i don't care
about that problem oh oh oh don't
scratch the cab oh no scratch the car go
ahead do whatever you want to do come on
let me hold the train
no that's their train
all right let me chill
let me chill let me chill
i'm not gonna do this today
i don't even need to tell you guys
anything you guys know why this is wrong
i got to train until okay hold on no you
hold on to that train don't let him take
that away from you nope
don't let him put the train on the car
please you need to tell me exactly what
happened
oh so you got the boys crying what you
took your shirt don't don't scratch the
car take it don't scratch the car
question give that a kiss get daddy kiss
the question look
can i pick them up yeah put them down
can i pick the kids up at the time
at the
time the kids up let go would you tell
me where you did so i can't pick the
kids up tell me what you did they got a
haircut yeah where
where earl you put a shaver to their
head how dare you do that
you finished
and your mom was gonna get the police
huh kim would you please have them get
the train off the car answer the
question i'm gonna take the train from
them okay and then they'll be balling
and it's all you that's it they can't
have the train on the car well then you
need to answer the question why don't
you back up from the card
back up from the car they're gonna
remember you as an image of taking this
away the emotion
you need counseling you need help lady
lady you need help
the manipulation is real you need help
who gave you the right to shave their
head what don't i pitch out support and
aren't they my kids too lord has nothing
to do you are non-custodial with
visitation you have no rights whatsoever
to do anything like this without
consulting with me first
oh here come your mama y'all know
everybody to get worse
kim
you see you can't have them let them
scratch up because i need to know what
you do i'm gonna give it back daddy
gonna give it back you can't scratch up
the car okay
here go over here
take him
give me
you leaving her
when is her coat
i don't know where's my coats where's my
stuff
this isn't that bag that you gave me oh
you did give me kota yes i did give you
coats girl and i gave you a hat and i
gave you food okay back up so i can open
the trunk go right ahead
can't wait baby
get the coats oh
once you're back up family they're
waiting for you
get the coats when she back up you can
go get them i don't want you behind
yeah now it's on our youtube channel
shout out to you mom
that's why you're such a coward girl
no no these are my
that's so typical
no thank you say another word to
i know
but don't you ever touch my children
like that again without consulting me i
am custodial i'm gonna give them a
haircut next time judgment doors you do
not touch that
i'm just telling you if they need a
haircut i'll give it to him if they need
a haircut i'll give it to him how's that
a threat
how's that a threat kids need haircuts
you need to get their their hair cut
okay oh my god you know what and look
i'm not mad if you would think you guys
should want or you want to make the
decision for i can understand but now
you guys have made it such a hostile
environment he feels like he can't back
down because you're trying to emasculate
him and basically make him a
non-existent father by saying you don't
get any say in the decision just
both of you guys are now contributing
but this woman is mad you're gonna cut
your hair cuz you want me to send you
the bill
you do not cut him yeah send me the bill
he's videotaping me i know so am i i'm
doing the same thing
remember what i said about uh ladies can
do whatever they want all right let's
keep going
[Applause]
back up
save yourself
what's your mommy's name
what's your name what's your mommy's
name
bruh
there's a kid in the car they're going
in the car asking the kid
you guys are wildin
you guys are wilin
it's not only good that you already
traumatized your two kids you want to
traumatize other people kid or now we
want a name we want to know who the name
of the other girl is lady you're hurt i
understand you're hurt
get some help
this not it this not it you and your mom
she got it from her mama i know why you
act like that now you're gonna go after
yo you're crazy you're crazy you don't
want her
you don't want him
to touch your kids
the kids that you guys have together
but you're gonna go ask question a grown
ad out to a kid that is not yours you're
out of place lady you're [ __ ] out of
place your mommy's name
not the cargo y'all are you touching me
get away from my car hey
did you just hurt me get away from the
car you just heard me get away from the
car you just put your hands on me
did you put your hands on me let's go
you put your hands on me i'm gonna have
a physical go ahead let me get it let's
go i'm about to complain again i'm about
to walk back to the police station
myself
put your hands on me leave it a child in
the car it's so typical
come on
[Music]
so whose kid was in the car seat
my kid or her kid they have three car
seats
in the front seat no i just put that in
the front seat in the front seat go get
a license foot in the front seat earl
look at the life
go get a license yeah go get a life
oh i have a life you're the one that
don't have a life you know when i was
killed you grow up you know your dad you
know your husband had a woman out there
in north carolina
you know
[Music]
you know earl i'm just why are you
following him
go home
i bet you won't
i won't even answer that i bet you won't
and you had
another girl while you were dating my
daughter i wish i did i wouldn't have
mad ass
i ain't even that's petty you know what
he said
he said
your husband had another woman in north
carolina and she went
i won't even answer that he's like i bet
you won't
i ain't even mad at that
i ain't
i don't think it's good parenting at all
but i know but but even my family i've
seen this yeah you ever seen me about
that [ __ ] yeah like i said i got
it's not my kids but somebody else cuz i
can't even see them yep you know what
i'm saying yeah and you try like you
tried to talk to both parties to figure
out what's cause i don't give a [ __ ]
anyone
that's like yo that that that's my
family so i'm gonna i just wanna be able
to be involved but like you realize it's
weird everything is weird everything is
through the lens like
it's not about the kit
it has nothing to do with the kid if the
two parents don't like each other they
will spiked out of spite they'll [ __ ]
over the kids yep they don't care
and
first off that's so sad yeah there's
your
the life that you're supposed to
prioritize above everything else you're
putting your own spite and your own
negative emotions over that and secondly
it's like you're destroying lives do you
hear what i'm saying yeah like when
somebody wants to desperately be
involved in their child's life and you
make it impossible or you make it so
difficult it's like that that that that
can drive people and that's a reason why
you need to take some steps why people
take some steps
when you love each other yes you know i
mean in order that when we don't love
each other [ __ ] is already going to be
set in stone because it's not when
people are going to have grudges it's
going to all that [ __ ] it goes out the
window whenever people think that
they don't that are not in the same
situation so it's
and some other [ __ ] and just it's
present it's like that people will do
that i just do this
do stuff different things out of spite
just to get to someone just to make some
someone pay or to trigger an emotion it
happens to some of my cousins that
happened to some of my cousins
they got
not to talk about their business but
they're gonna get triggered out of spite
just to just to get to them mr i'm gonna
show you i got power i can't hit you
perfect i'm gonna hit you somewhere else
i'ma hit you where it really really
hurts it's crazy yeah ma one of my
homies said he was recorded his girl and
he played the recording for me and she
said listen
she says you know what i can do if you
don't want any problems handle this
properly
stop playing with me
and i was just sitting there thinking
like damn she knows what she can do
she knows how this [ __ ] favors her
right and it's very easy for this kind
of stuff to spiral out of control
especially if you can't afford the
proper lawyer to set this up and get
good representation get the
documentation you need make sure that
conversations are recorded or set up by
email so there's a written trace to show
like your financial involvement don't
handle cash make sure it's all these
kinds of things that you're supposed to
know to establish like your presence in
your child's life is it obvious to most
people so you could be doing all the
right things to try to be involved with
the child and if she don't [ __ ] with it
it doesn't matter it doesn't matter
right so i've had to witness it from so
many people around me so sometimes if
you were like oh i don't get why some of
these dudes are jaded it's like i
understand like imagine having your
[ __ ] child ripped from you yeah i got
one of my friends imagine having
your
kin your blood
six years deny it to you and you you
have to live through online photos right
you gotta go on social media to find out
about your own child
and updates that's crazy yeah one of my
friends six years he didn't see his kids
six years
going on seven
so you missed all of that
two of his kids
child support too
oh you oh that you yeah that you pay
because if you don't
go there you go you don't know play
about that no but you're not going to
see that you're not going to see the
product of because you want to get back
at the person forget the kids [ __ ] them
kids it's really that it's crazy yeah
and from the women's perspective
sometimes she's put in a position or a
situation that she's not the happiest
about you know because the fact that
she's having to raise a kid and the
father doesn't want to be in her life or
she doesn't want him to be in her life
so she's resentful to some degree of her
circumstances there's a lot of women who
are mothers who are upset about their
circumstance right and and blame in
large part their partner right and it's
a power thing at that point
so that's also a factor and i can
understand like listen it's not an easy
situation being a single mom i'm gonna
say here i'm like yeah yeah y'all
of course but to deny
it's like sometimes single moms will get
a lot of love
oh look at the sacrifice they made for
their kid
they not all like that sometimes they
will spite their
just despite their husbands or exes or
whatever they will [ __ ] over their kids
or here's nothing that they do
this is something i just think is so
nefarious and weird they'll go to their
child and speak terribly on the father
just because you have a problem with
doesn't mean somebody else is going to
have that problem with them too
just because you don't need him doesn't
mean the child doesn't need its father
or mother irrespective of the
circumstance but a lot of these women
don't give a [ __ ] they'll lie they'll
say stuff it's kind of like that story
that dude who went on yala and said and
the mother said that he had touched his
own kids she and she admitted to lying
she admitted she made that that whole
thing up after 50 they their whole life
they grew up thinking like their father
was like a diddler you get what i'm
saying and the reason why i've raised my
voice when i think about some stuff
she's like yo i see the injustice
i see it firsthand and the people around
me of course it gets me heated because i
see how it negatively impacts them
i see it firsthand
and it's just like brother it's a hard
thing to stomach it's a very difficult
thing to stop and you look at some of
these women they don't give up [ __ ]
they don't care
virus what were you thinking
no that's pretty much it man i was just
thinking about you know it
just puts it back in your face yeah and
i mean and it's just crazy
it's really bad
hurt people hurt people